i think one thing i was always jealous
of americans is that like
it just seems like they just accept any
side of like weird culture yeah yeah
yeah yeah uk and probably australia as
well right it felt that like if you were
into stuff that wasn't like super normal
it felt like
being from the uk or australia watching
american conventions or like seeing just
the way they treat nerd culture in
general and yes was i was always so
jealous
one of the reasons why i always wanted
to move to the u.s i mean obviously now
it's
very different yes kids have an easy
time i didn't give a [ __ ] back then i
was like i'll go anywhere
right because back then to me america
was like this whole like mystical place
and then obviously now mystical place
it was it was like it was like a place
where everyone could just do what they
wanted yeah and like
everyone could like like whatever they
wanted yeah there's always a huge
always like a huge place to go if you
liked a specific thing that was always a
big convention
i think it's also because like
especially compared to like the uk
especially like
america was just so much [ __ ] bigger
right so there's just it just felt like
there was more stuff
there was like huge nerds and like
otakus in the uk but
because you were again you were just
like looking down we couldn't find each
other
that was the biggest thing because in
america it seems like there was always a
place for somewhere
wherever you wanted to belong yeah and i
remember looking at ax or or like all
these con videos and thinking
man god i wish that was yeah
i look like i belong there oh my god i
remember when i went to my very very
first convention
and i just felt like this was right like
i knew that this was where my heart was
supposed to be i saw that too when i
took a convention because then it's just
like remember like fact that like
because we could not find each other and
even in the us it was still like this
was more online
than anything but when you found
someone's like oh you like naruto too
like oh my and then you just instantly
connected well in australia there wasn't
even an online scene like
i feel like it's almost like in america
like i don't know if this is true but
like parents kind of like
are more accepting of like weird hobbies
yeah yeah
in the uk man my parents would give me
[ __ ] yeah my parents were like that
close
like come down for dinner be like oh
it's the anime fan
okay yeah my parents used to like be
really
kind of like weirded out about the fact
i like the anime but now
my parents are very rare for their
generation they love youtubers and
streamers they tell me [ __ ] that even
like i haven't caught up to yet
like yeah yeah yeah like they they know
literally everyone and then uh so
what's funny is like i'm logged into my
youtube account also on
uh the one at home back in vegas the
reason for that is because
because of time zones my mom checks to
see if i got like a content
like copyright claim and she goes to my
account and then
she's literally your manager yeah like
she she claims that for me and then i
wake up the next morning i was like mom
did you claim this sorry she's like yeah
yeah i was just looking at it
well my mom's like who's your swiss
friend ppd yeah yeah
my mom will occasionally go and there's
been a big youtuber in the news
i heard this logan fellow i couldn't
believe it
do you know him
my parents are have definitely done
their hardest to try and like keep up
with the times
yeah my parents do try but they're just
too out of it
yeah yeah my parents are the same my
parents have really changed since trash
day started because that's just given
them
so much content to watch and now it's
gotten to the point where
every single clip and every single now
we have like official
and then unofficial clip streams as well
yeah and that's all been recommended to
her
and she watches she watches like way
more content than i do now
she's purely off like us i guess yeah my
parents are kind of just like
you know we don't like support what you
do you just kind of do it yeah
so we don't support what you do but you
do your own challenge no no my dad
no my dad you do not support joey and
his job
no my dad's straight like in the q a
that i did with my dad my dad was
straight up like
i don't really like support what you do
i just kind of let you do it i'm like
thanks dad the only thing about having
parents that are so
in tune with what i do is like that
would annoy me i would it would annoy me
giving me feedback about my thumbnails
my dad doesn't give a [ __ ] about what i
do and yet he's still like yeah son i
didn't really like that video you made
yeah it's like same as my friends
yeah no and then dude my parents like
like they used to back when it was like
used more they looked at like social
blades and stuff like they were
they're very into like that's like a
little too
much i don't want my parents to yeah my
my dad
was he went through a point when he was
just literally clicking and refreshing
it
and i was like dad this is not healthy
why are you doing this please
that's kind of cute though i don't know
why it's like oh i want to see you girl
yeah i occasionally get my mom she'll be
like oh the last video i didn't do as
well as the other videos yeah
my mom not everyone can be
my dad would sometimes phone me and be
like son last week you only grew like
1 000 subscribers oh my god normally you
grow like 2 000
what's going on what is your channel
dying your channel dying what's going on
yeah my my dad right now he's like
having his own version of like you
winning son it's more like oh yeah
your video doing well like it's just
every upload he just said has the sex
it's cute though i like